leo's with us in atlanta hi leo how are
you
hey doug how you doing better than i
deserve how can i help
hey dave i have a good problem being
debt free and i won't see if you can
kind of help me out on it
right um 29 years old um i have
have everything paid for including my
house thank thanks to listen to your
show and everything
it's about 500 000 dollars my house
value
and i have a business that i was able to
pay everything off with
with all this corona stuff going on i
i'm
very on the edge meeting with clients
and i kind of want to go meet with
clients because
sometimes i feel like i don't need to
expose myself but i feel like i know
this virus is going to end and my
business has to continue
and i just want to get your help kind of
getting me out of that mindset or
your thoughts what kind of clients do
you have
i work in a landscape business on the
landscape business and when the clients
i go meet with the clients they're first
thing they come approach me
and i just get really urgy and kind of
you know
with them getting near me and are you
ill
i'm not okay and so how old are you
29 so you're a healthy 29 year old
yes okay uh i would suggest you turn off
your television
the fear porn has gotten you
it has yeah and and you know
i i don't know i'm 60 i did the math
it's like a 0.001
less than one percent chance i'm going
to die from this um
and so i if you want to hug my neck i'll
hug you
if you're if you're scared and you maybe
you got somebody ill in your family and
you want to wear a mask that's fine too
i'm good with that um if you want to
shake my hand i'll shake your hand i'm
gonna go wash my hands but that's what i
did anyway back when there was flu
so um uh i mean but you know
uh lots of people have lots of opinions
about this so i would be more concerned
not about your health personally i mean
you you got to decide but i think you
probably need to
get some different inputs is my opinion
and you ask my opinion which is
dangerous i'm an expert on that
but i think you get some different
inputs on what the actual
facts are because there are people that
their
fear is based as if this
is a as if you get it you're going to
die
and the death rate is so very low
on this that um that that again if
you're if you've got an illness or
you've got a susceptibility i would
never want anybody to be harmed
and certainly you would respect your
customers
what they want to do uh there's a
hundred people sitting outside the lobby
or 50 people or whatever it is sitting
outside in the lobby some are wearing
masks they're my friends
some of them aren't wearing masks
they're my friends some of them that
didn't come because they were scared
they're my friends that's right
so i respect you wherever you are and
you can do whatever you want to do with
that stuff
uh but then you but i think what you're
describing is more what's happening
inside your head
and i think you just gotta study some of
the other information that's out there
because
one of the things we have discovered
through this whole thing is they don't
teach math in med school
these people the models and the stuff
are just
they're ludicrous and um the the data
points on this thing is
just just silly you can honestly in the
news they find whatever it is you want
to believe
yeah i mean you truly can and i i think
in leo's situation
i'm going to let the customer determine
that meaning as i contact them and if
he's obviously as a landscaper
he said he gets afraid when the customer
walks right i know but but
like you said that's psychological uh
you just got to stop with that and just
say
you know you just stop it you're a great
counselor you just stop
because what you're doing is you're
psyching yourself out uh
and that that's called a self-fulfilling
prophecy it is but but you know what it
means to us is what you believe is
causing that
right and so you've got to decide do i
if you truly believe you're going to
become ill and die as a result of that
then a normal human being would be
psyched out
oh big time normally i mean that would
be normal no one no one that has good
sense would walk into another human's
presence
if you thought as a result of that
you're going to die and so what's
happening is you
i'm was being sarcastic but not really
turn off the tv news
because it's fear porn is what it is
people are addicted to fear
like they're addicted to porn and
they're just feed me more fear feed me
more fear feed me more fear run my
anxiety up run my anxiety up
make me think the world's coming to an
end and man they can they can put it out
there yeah
that's a that's a terrible way to live
um
and i really would i would talk to
someone i really you know for yourself
individually
but be honest about what is it you're
scared of and what are your
probabilities
right because right actually
statistically you're probably more
at risk when you drove over there on the
highway
actually if you actually look at the i
mean i mean
now car wrecks are different than
viruses i understand i'm not a flat
earther
shut up but my god but i mean it
it's um statistically you know we always
use the thing
actual statistics actual probability of
statistics when you're buying a lotto
ticket
if you walk one mile to the market and
one mile home
you are statistically more likely to be
struck by lightning
twice than by the lotto ticket that wins
but in spite of that people buy a lotto
ticket
why not because of the actual math and
facts
because anybody that looks at that goes
the chances of me being struck by
lightning
twice on my walk over there and back is
like so infinitesimal but so is your
chance of
winning the lotto doofus you know and so
in his case you know
you look at your risk and you look at
what the death rate of a healthy 29 year
old is
no in your state the death rate
now could you get the equivalent of the
flu we've had
eight or ten people here at the office
have had it and
as one was really ill and the rest of
them
many of them didn't realize they had it
and then all the testing issues
come into play there so you need to get
information that you feel comfortable
with and act on
that and is your fear logical john
dolone always says dr john always says
facts are your friends and so when i'm
analyzing something like this i'm not
i'm not taking a poll i'm not worried
about social pressure you can kiss my
butt i'm going to do what i want to do
i don't care about what you think about
me i'm way past that a long time ago
if you're offended i'm sorry but i'm not
really sorry
and sorry not sorry no you know but what
i do want to know is i really do want to
know what the actual facts are
am i bringing harm to someone or is
someone going to bring harm to me
those are the only facts i'm really
worried about what are the real numbers
and when you look at the actual
math then it might help you with that
fear
it's a good call if it doesn't then you
may need to do something different until
you get
get straightened out on that this is the
dave ramsey show